from timcast.com
breaking
florida senate passes legislation ending
disney's tax privilege self-governing
power and special exemption status so
ron desantis the governor of florida is
like they could have they can just build
a nuclear power plant on their own like
they're able to do certain things that
nobody else is able to do so i think
they're right to be looking at this and
reevaluating it i want to say the most
important element of this story is that
disney decided to get woke they thought
they could push the the push all of us
around and say you know what the
activists employees are complaining
about wokeness let's just give them what
they want well now they are seeing that
you reap what you sow you want to come
out and you and you think that you can
just adopt ideology
say you will be political disney was
outright like we're going to defeat this
bill florida said okay you want to get
political we'll take away your special
status now we're seeing as of today
their stock has dropped by 5.56 percent
on top of that their stock was already
hurting this year it's good to see real
economic consequences right freedom of
speech doesn't mean freedom from
consequences right disney
i want to see more companies who want to
act a fool and play dirty games
see actual
accountability my thoughts were
yes you break up that big corporate
you know monopoly break it up that's why
we have anti-trust laws that's why we
have a government in places to protect
us from these insidious things like
corporate people whatever but tom when
you came in here you made a great point
that how far is this going to go how
much authority should a government have
to stop the private sector
well you know look disney is uh the
leadership of disney is abusing
shareholder dollars by uh spending them
improperly
to target or promote talking uh about
sexual activities with young school
children
and uh if you're a shareholder you're
you ought to be saying why aren't you
producing more and better product
and increasing shareholder value should
just real quick i mean at that point
should the shareholders sue for a
violation of their of the company's
fiduciary duty
well i ain't no lawyer but uh
the people have been sued for less
that's for sure in terms of stock with
stock fights and things like that and
shareholder uh lawsuits
but secondly though you've got this
special
position that disney has in florida it's
been around since 1967
and they're talking about taking away
some governance that benefits disney
corporate wise and arguably the state
and so the concern i have is is this
being considered
for
uh reasons that are
neutrally applied meaning it's a bad
idea to provide
corporations these special
tax incentives and such
or is it a political payback and if it's
the second one
the danger is
that look the left almost always
controls the leverage of power
so if the new standard is that if
corporations break free and you know
start engaged in politics the way disney
has either on the left or the right is
it going to be a free-for-all in terms
of punishing corporations through
government action
let's say in california they go after a
defense contractor or in new york they
go after a gun manufacturer uh and uh
well in fact that's actually what's
happening yeah there are right they're
already talking about doing that without
any of this being right it's already
happening right and it's and it's been
consistently people who oppose the cult
wokeness fringe
ideology who have been getting attacked
what's happening isn't it like what this
is like the first time republicans are
like okay you know what we're not going
to tolerate you getting into this and
and to be clear i'm not saying i oppose
what florida did i'm just highlighting
well let's let's be aware of what's
happening out there in the culture and
that corporations when they engage in
politics
there's going to be payback
now and again and you know florida is
making a policy decision they got this
major corporation
that's decided to take the benefits
they're getting from the public
and target school children
and so that's the reaction you're going
to get from the elected representatives
of the public well you're not going to
use to say these special benefits
anymore
uh on behalf of an agenda that we didn't
sign up for when we gave them to you to
begin with i don't i don't think it's as
bad as
as you as you might be making it seem
whether it's intention or not this is
disney who has no business in education
policy
deciding to come out because a fringe
faction of activists at their company
complained they ignore the the activists
of the company who are like we don't
want to be involved in this if a gun
company in new york said we're going to
lobby for gun rights that makes sense
if disney said we're going to lobby for
entertainment rights and special
privileges i'd be like okay well that
makes sense
if a gun manufacturer gun manufacturer
came out and said we're going to start
dumping money into getting religion put
in schools i'd be like they shouldn't be
doing that if they started saying you
know if they said our mission is to
defeat they said like you're a gun
company what are you doing disney's
doing that doing exactly that they have
no business they're doing it for pr
reasons well if they want to be involved
in politics as a political organization
they got to play by the rules and this
is what happened i'll tell you what man
disney has been attempting to educate
kids since the inception of the company
they make cartoons for little kids and
they put subliminal ideas like the
develop you see all sorts of crazy
occult stuff in it um if you really look
for and there's tons of uh youtube
videos about it conspiracy or whatever
but that's the basic indoctrination of
children is cartoons on tv and that's
disney's specialty so i'm not really
even i mean walt was a great man but
when he died so in my opinion so did
that company man it's no longer they
should have to change the name or
something that's abusive we'll read
through some of these super chats but
someone did mention just now the
buildings probably aren't up to code
so if if disney it's disney world i
think right whatever yeah in florida if
they're under a special governing status
i'm willing to bet they do not conform
to florida building code which means now
that they lose this status yo they're
going to get shut down i mean what
they're this
hey you want to bring disney to heel
this is how you do it and when you see
into ian's point uh i think it was
christopher ruffo who
disclosed these zoom meetings with
disney producers and executives and
creators
talking about pushing their agenda this
radical sexual identity agenda
in the cartoons and in the content
targeting your children
so
for all the caution let's be clear here
disney is engaged by their own admission
in pushing propaganda on young children
that parents would reject and taxpayers
want no part of in florida that's what's
clear this wouldn't be happening if the
politicians didn't think
our voters don't you know want this and
certainly disney has their ability every
right and they've got all the money in
the world to persuade uh the voters
otherwise to keep their special benefits
but
it's a hard argument to make
yeah um so disney is not a company that
i happen to be a fan of ian i i agree
with a lot of what you said and i agree
with what you're saying now they
essentially want to use their platform
to to push and normalize perverse sexual
lifestyle choices onto children on top
of that they have sex abuse scandals we
know that they have hired people who
were convicted of child sex abuse in the
past and the disney channel specifically
so not a good company
yes icarly was that what it was i'm not
so oh there there's talk about that
there's talk about that but i'm
referring specifically to brian peck
um who was
uh convicted
and then later after he served uh hired
by disney to consult over the phone
because he wasn't allowed to actually be
in the presence of children and then
there was also there's this if you just
look at these memes
every few months they arrest child
traffickers at disney well i mean
of course these people are going to want
to work there right they want to get
access to kids and disney apparently
doesn't do enough screening to stop them
or they're not paying attention to the
trafficking that's occurring under their
noses i mean you know we're all
concerned about critical race theory in
the schools but at least there's like
political accountability there in theory
so everything you're concerned about in
the schools is already happening on the
disney channel
nickelodeon and it's all targeted very
young children
the far left is taking control of
children's programming and it isn't just
uh reading writing and arithmetic
teaching kids how to read it's
social cultural transformation
uh on television and disney's now being
kind of forced to admit it
uh because you know they're they're in
the business of teaching their kids
teaching your kids
values that are very different than the
parents expect from the content and if i
well i am a parent but we don't we don't
watch those visiting shows anymore but i
would not allow any of this children's
program to be seen by my children until
i had seen it first don't give your kids
cell phones yeah homeschooling kids so i
i'll only i defer to the big tech ceos
these these these executives who don't
give their kids cell phones
why is it that the people who work at
you know big social media companies are
like i am like i'm not gonna let my kid
have a phone cause they know what's on
these websites have you noticed like
this weird psycho social psychosis of
the last decade has really coincided
with the proliferation of these devices
too absolutely mm-hmm
it's it's simple when someone's in a
cult to get them out of the cult you
have to separate them from cult members
and deprogram them
but with the existing woke cult it's
right there in the palm of their hands
every every time someone says something
you know hey this isn't true you need to
get away from this they retreat back to
their fantasy world and the most
vulnerable is the children that's the
reason i'll tell you i'll tell you right
now what's what's one of the most
infuriating things because i i can't
stand the media lying is the taylor
lorenz story where washington post
and i'll show a clarification for things
i was saying yesterday and things i said
today because i want to make sure i get
all the facts correct in the original
washington post article that doxed the
creator of libs of tick tock they linked
to a real estate license which included
a private home address
it was a commercial residential mixed
property listed as a business address
but also according to public records a
private residential address for the
creator of the libs of tick tock and
they also explained they didn't link to
they explained how to get their their
private phone number so
they said you know the phone record is
found here associated with this domain
which took me two seconds to just google
and then three seconds to do a dns so
i'm not but but i want to be careful
with my language they didn't link to the
number they just told you
gave you the instructions the name you
needed to look for with the thing to
find it and so uh this one's really
frustrating because i'm seeing many
prominent left-wing personalities just
go they never linked to any private
details i'm seeing the washington post
say we never link to private details and
i'm like yo these people are in a cult
well some of them are saying they never
linked to private details and some of
them are saying that it's good that they
link to private details i'm seeing both
takes well now the the the door's been
opened on that one and you know this guy
responded to me and he's like tim your
followers have been doing this for years
and i'm like i don't think you watch my
show i don't think you know who our
followers are like we we don't we don't
have that kind of audience you can't
control your followers you can only give
them advice and guidance but it's
everyone has to make their own choice we
don't have followers who do that stuff
like i mean i'm sure there's a couple
people here and there watch the show but
we are not on these platforms where
we're engaging in overt activism in fact
you know i told the guy
i think doxxing the name of libs of
tic-tac was wrong and he's like you mean
to tell me that if you got the name of
some antifa count you wouldn't publish
the name and i was like yes i would not
probably how many times have you guys
heard me say i won't say their name i
say it all the time minimize harm i even
i even sometimes refuse to say jenk
yuger's name when the story is about the
youngest it's true because i'm trying to
avoid drama and trying to talk about
concepts and and philosophy these people
they don't
i feel like their goal is specifically
to keep people in the dark for political
power they are evil when the washington
post came out and said we never did that
and you can pull up the archive and just
see that they did i'm like these people
are downright evil so are they lying
they they put a link to this address is
that different than posts
no they said we did not link to it
outright
i will assert as a statement of fact the
washington post
linked to the private home address of
the creator of libs of tick tock it's as
if they didn't think they were doing it
so then they said they didn't but they
did
well and then just lying because they're
evil people yeah and even if they didn't
know that's almost worse and then they
deleted it so obviously they knew
yep they edited the page good point you
know i i think a lot of these media
become
you know they sometimes engage in
journalism but places like the
washington post have just become
left-wing advocacy groups that sometimes
create journalism that's valuable but
you know judicial watch you know we're a
non-profit we do lots of
uh talking about policy we educate
people we do journalism
but you know i would be hard to argue
that we weren't advocating for certain
values and the washington post is
more activists than any political group
group i know
in the movements of both the left or the
right in terms of pushing forward
narratives and agendas and in the case
of lawrence
or or outing the uh author of the lives
of tick tock uh
tweet feed
it wasn't
it's problematic obviously that they uh
exposed her but more importantly they
lied about the content and it wasn't it
was exposing her to attack and belittle
the content
and cut off
access to it from the public or is a
judicial watch a 501c3 or c4 so we're a
501c3 which to those who don't follow
the irs code means we're a charity
meaning you we can take tax deductible
contributions it also means you can't
engage in overtly political activity
uh it generally means that we can't uh
endorse or oppose candidates yeah and
you know i can talk about politics but i
can't uh you know say vote for
republicans or democrats can you say who
you're gonna vote for
i could in my personal capacity uh but i
choose not to generally because of the
nature of our work because we end up
suing everyone i want to give taylor the
benefit of the doubt really quick
because it's possible that when she
wrote this article she thought she was
linking to the business address and then
it went up and then they were like we
didn't we didn't we do it and then when
they realized they did they pulled it
down she's still denying it and so we're
now we're awaiting them to be like
actually we accidentally we did no that
is the benefit of the doubt at least ian
you can't she did she outright denied it
to me but it doesn't matter what she
said they did it i know they did yes she
outright denied it to me personally i
did not publish the home address then
the washington post said we didn't link
to private information they are just
lying on top of lies because they are
not good people don't give them the
benefit of that when they're lying ex
like overtly and i'm just i'm
flabbergasted by the it's like imagine
being is that family guy joke imagine
being in an elevator with one other
person who just lets out a big fart
looked at you and says you did it i'm
like what yeah i was like dude i watched
you do it what are you lying the benefit
of the doubt in that i want to
understand why it happened and never a
tribute to malice what could have been
attributed to stupidity it's a thing
i've heard in the past so maybe
i mean
you know my my view on the post now is
if a post reporter called me up to find
out where a court hearing is say oh yeah
what's here what's the case about it's
about this
but if they're calling me up to talk
about conservatives and
what's our view on topic a and b
i say i'm not talking to you i mean
you're you're left-wing just honest
advocates and i'm not going to waste my
breath talking and explaining our views
to you what so you can attack
whoever it is you're trying to attack
usually people who are aligned with our
values and they're playing their game i
want to make sure everybody understands
this there is no way you can talk to a
journalist you are not smarter than them
they have a plan they know what they're
doing you will not go on the daily show
you will not go on jim jeffries you will
not go on john oliver you think you're
smart you think if i explain my
positions i'll tell you some of the
tricks they do first of all when it
comes to these comedy news shows they'll
just manipulate what you said because
they're allowed to do it because it's a
comedy show but let's say
you tell a journalist something
explicitly like i reject and refuse
the uh i completely reject racism it is
completely wrong
and i i oppose these racist
organizations
instead of quoting you if they want to
get a narrative they will say when asked
about their racist ties they became
belligerent huh
right and you'll be like but i told them
they don't have to put that in there
they can just say they became outraged
and belligerent
i i believe it was because they were
truly racist and they won't tell the
world what you said i had a guy hit me
up from the daily beast and i gave him
quotes he cut out any quote that made me
look good and then here's another trick
they do you think you can give them a
good quote just one solid quote they
might still use it with ellipses you'll
say something like that man who came out
and said
pizza is disgusting that man was wrong
and they'll put dot quote dot dot pizza
and they'll say he literally said those
words and when you were like i was
quoting someone else they're like did
you you can't sue him over it it's not
it's a statement of fact that said you
said it and you can be like that but but
i wasn't referring to that way but you
did it yeah it's the story i want to
mention about this reporter from the
boston globe who wrote that based stick
man this is back during the battle of
berkeley several years ago was a white
nationalist and i messaged him and i was
like i saw you wrote that and like this
guy's got a got a
his wife's like you know asian mixed
race he's got a mixed race kid it's like
i think you're wrong and he goes is the
guy white i said yes is he a nationalist
yes he's a white nationalist and i was
like wow dude you can't have to follow
you cannot talk to these people right
and so we see this all the time happen
jordan clapper i think his name is he
shows up to these rallies and these
people think they can talk to him and
then what he does is he cuts it all up
and makes him look insane and then he
puts it on tv and who's he with
uh it's comedy central i don't know if
he's still doing it maybe he's on the
daily show now whatever yeah but they
all do it another problem with these
like live
shows with live audiences is unless the
host is willing to tell the audience to
shut up when they start booing and
heckling the audience will shout you
down when you're making a good point and
then the host will be like if they have
an agenda so you need like an ethical
host to like keep everything ordered not
jon stewart that dude's ratings are in
the gutter yeah i mean i used to do
politically incorrect back in the day
back when mar was on abc and you know
i'd be the lone conservative typically
and getting booed all the time for the
entire half hour and uh you know it's
not fun
but you know at least you get to say
your piece because it's it's hard to
edit what you're saying right those are
better but but uh i agree with you uh
you know generally talking to the media
is a bad idea i used to talk to
reporters at the daily beast and i
stopped talking to them because i give
them a quote and the headline would be
conservatives get hysterical about x yes
i'm not playing i'm not giving you
material to attack
america with i'm not doing it anymore
and it's kind of a it's tricky for
because you know judicial watch our goal
is to educate people so i want the word
about everywhere but you know when it
comes to the media it's been so
corrupted
uh
we can't play their game anymore and and
even even uh there are many prominent
youtube personalities independent uh
personalities who are progressive or
liberal and it's remarkable how either
they are completely incompetent or are
just outright lying and i i'm confused
by this but i won't give any i don't
give these people the benefit benefit of
the doubt anymore because i there
there's there's a few people that i've
actually dm'd with and i'm like here's
the public record
here's the link to the story here's a
screen grab showing where you can click
it to get the address we don't need to
argue whether it was libs of tick tock's
private home address regardless it was a
private contact address for the
individual
no it wasn't
and i'm like
you know what there's no point talking
to tribalists no i think making your own
youtube videos or internet videos is
really the way to go it's they can
attempt to take it out of context and
they can unethically sometimes kind of
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you